jack the ripper ist wohl einer der
bekanntesten serienmörder überhaupt und
wirklich brutal noch dazu mindestens
fünf frauen in london steht da 888 die
kehle durch und verstümmelte seine opfer
was möglich ist bis heute ist ungeklärt
welcher der damaligen verdächtigen
wirklich hinter jack the ripper steckte
ist doch jetzt hat ein forschungsteam
diesen mysteriösen kriminalfall noch
einmal aufgerollt mit hilfe von modernen
genetischen analysen soll jetzt endlich
die wahre identität des serienmörders
entlarvt worden sein
pixum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
mich herzlich willkommen insgesamt vier
verdächtige standen damals ganz oben auf
der liste der londoner polizei ein
anwalt ein russischer arzt und ex
sträfling und ein quacksalber aus urlaub
zu dem auch ein papier mit psychischen
problemen dieser pole mit dem namen
aaron kosminski gar damals als
hauptverdächtiger in dem fall
doch der wirklich mehr als mysteriöse
kriminalfall machte den ermittlern von
scotland yard schwer zu schaffen denn
jack wille war da wirklich besonders
blutrünstig er brachte seine opfer nicht
nur um sondern verstümmelte sie dann
auch noch auf bestialische art und weise
ganz london hatte damals angst bei
dunkelheit auf die straße zu gehen mehr
als 70 tatverdächtige wurden seit 1888
mit den morden in verbindung gebracht
dennoch wurde jack the ripper nie
gefasst denn bis heute haben es die
ermittlungsbehörden nicht geschafft die
identität des serienkillers aufzuklären
dabei sind seine morde mittlerweile
schon 131 jahre her das problem
es fehlten nicht nur die spuren vom
täter erschwerend hinzu kam dass es so
etwas wie dna analysen zu dieser zeit
noch nicht gab
selbst bei der ermittlungsarbeit mit
fingerabdrücken fehlte die erfahrung die
einzigen anhaltspunkte damals waren
briefe und ein schal der mit blut
verschmiert war mittlerweile glauben
fachleute zudem dass die briefe nicht
echt war blieb und bleibt also nur der
blutverschmierte schal der übrigens am
fundort des vierten opfers gefunden
wurde dieser diente jetzt auch den
britischen forschungsteam als grundlage
um den kriminalfall noch einmal
aufzurollen dafür nahmen sie proben aus
dem schal und scannten diese auf die
sogenannte mitochondriale dna
damit ist gut gemeint dass mütter an
ihre kinder weiter
das ergebnis dieser dna analyse
verglichen sie dann mit der dna der
verwandten des damaligen opfers kanye
west doch nicht nur das
das forschungsteam stellte zudem auch
ein vergleich mit der dna einer
nachfahrin des damaligen
hauptverdächtigen dem barbier aus polen
namens aaron kosminski und die dna
analyse lieferte gleich zwei spannende
ergebnisse zum einen zeigten die
vergleichswerte dass die dna der
blutflecken zu der des opfers passte
also eine bestätigung dafür dass der
blutverschmierte schal vom fundort
tatsächlich zum vierten opfer kathrin
etwas passt und dann die zweite
erkenntnis diejenigen dna schnipsel die
nicht vom opfer stamm stimmen laut des
britischen forschungsteams mit dem
erbgut der kosminski nachfahrin überein
die beiden wissenschaftler werten dieses
ergebnis als möglichen beleg dafür dass
der damals hauptverdächtige codes winski
also tatsächlich der mörder von kathrin
elvis war und somit auch jack the ripper
als weitere indizien für diese annahme
nehmen sie die ergebnisse der dna
analyse die zeigen dass der mörder des
opfers wohl braune haare und augen hat
dazu die beiden forscher david miller
und jahre nur hellenen damit passt
dieses phänotypisch informationen zu dem
einzigen historischen zeugenbericht der
als zuverlässig gilt andere fachleute
sehen die analyse und die daraus
abgeleiteten schlussfolgerungen des
britischen forschungsteams mit skepsis
zum einen seien die ergebnisse nicht
überprüft und nachvollziehbar da die dna
sequenzen in der neuen studie nicht mit
veröffentlicht wurden
müller und lehnen dagegen argumentieren
dass der datenschutz einer
veröffentlichung dieser sensiblen daten
im wege stehe
doch auch ein weiterer punkt lässt
andere experten und expertinnen an der
aktuellen studie zweifeln
demnach sei die mitochondriale dna nicht
wirklich dazu geeignet um eine enge
verwandtschaft zu beweisen diese sei
lediglich sinnvoll unverdächtige
auszuschließen somit müsste also auch
eine dna analyse der anderen damals
verdächtigen personen erfolgen um ihre
schuld auszuschließen
das perfekte verbrechen ist es möglich
anklicken anschauen darunter schreiben
wie ihr peter knollmann finden und
natürlich klicks um science-fiction
abonnieren fal si
noch nicht getan haben sollte bis dann
bleibt dran